[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public en étant
ensemble tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et 22h pour donner du sens à
l'actualité et voici le sommaire de ce
lundi 13 février mettre le pays à
l'arrêt le 7 mars c'est le rendez-vous
donné par l'intersyndical après les
manifestations de samedi violence
verbale à l'Assemblée nationale coup de
téléphone d'Elizabeth borne au leader
syndicaux ce week-end s'il en Emmanuel
Macron stratégie de la nuque beaucoup de
thèmes passionnante à aborder juste
après ces titres et puis pour notre
débat volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour c'est un chiffre que
je vous propose 97 comme le nombre de
détenus condamnés pour terrorisme sorti
l'an dernier de prison après avoir purgé
leur peine ils étaient moins nombreux
les deux années précédentes ils seront
encore une centaine cette année qu'il
les surveille comment savoir s'ils ont
renoncé au terrorisme islamistes que
faire aussi des femmes et des enfants
récemment rapatriés des camps de Siri ne
ratez pas l'analyse de nos exp dans 45
minutes mais d'abord donc cette réforme
des retraites et le compte à rebours
lancés à l'Assemblée dernière semaine de
débat avant que la loi n'arrive au Sénat
et le climat social qui se durcit
Jonathan du priez mesdames et messieurs
la pression s'accentue sur l'exécutif
l'Inter syndical toujours unique contre
la réforme des retraites semble ouvrir
la voie à un durcissement du mouvement
et appelle à mettre la France à l'art et
le 7 mars prochain un ultimatum
implicite adressé au gouvernement pour
qu'il retire son projet de réforme
inacceptable pour certains ministres
soit vous retirez votre réforme parce
que c'est cela que cela veut dire
c'est-à-dire vous retirez l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite à 64 ans soit nous
bloquons le pays cette logique là n'est
pas recevable les concessions ne peuvent
pas être à sens unique nous avons fait
des gestes nous avons fait des
ouvertures la première ministre a cessé
de dialoguer avec les syndicats c'est au
Parlement désormais que se joue le débat
que se joue le sort du texte sauf que
l'incertitude plane sur l'issue des
débats au Palais Bourbon il ne reste
qu'une semaine pour examiner les 15000
amendements déposés par l'opposition
l'article 7 de la réforme sur le report
de l'âge légal pourrait ne pas être
débattue par les députés le gouvernement
et les syndicats dénoncent cette
obstruction parle commentaires de la
France insoumise notamment qui
risquerait selon eux de confisquer le
débat démocratique aux Français nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait un vote sur
article 7 que chaque député puisse
s'exprimer pour pas que
à la fin des débats certains nous disent
mais moi j'ai jamais voté pour
l'allongement de l'âge de la retraite
parce qu'il n'y aura pas eu de vote
comme priorité entre le débat
parlementaire et la rue le gouvernement
tente toujours de jouer l'apaisement
Elisabeth borne a appelé plusieurs
responsables syndicaux en ce sens sont
toutefois à faire vaciller l'union
sacrée des centrales contre la réforme
lors de la prochaine journée de
mobilisation ce jeudi les syndicats
manifesteront à Albi dans le Tarn une
manière de souligner leur unité mais
surtout d'insister sur l'ancrage du
mouvement social sur l'ensemble du
territoire
[Musique]
il faut absolument garder l'accroche
populaire il faut être soutenu par sa
base et donc on l'a vu il y a une
stratégie de l'Inter syndicale qui fait
d'ailleurs que les sensibilités des
différences syndicats doivent
s'harmoniser pour garder l'opinion avec
le vent en donc oui on ménage le temps
parlementaire on ménage les vacances sur
la question du temps parlementaire il y
a quand même une question qui va falloir
qu'on se pose tous au bout d'un moment
donné c'est qui cristallise un petit peu
ses débats au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que c'est vraiment les
groupes d'opposition en tout cas on voit
bien que l'Inter syndical a un discours
et que les parlementaires en ont un
autre un style d'ailleurs qui est
différent et donc peut-être qu'il y a
une question de relais de l'un à l'autre
alors après il y a aussi cette grande
idée du blocage comme ultimatum c'est à
dire que plus vous laissez tant plus
vous montrer que finalement vous avez
montré pas de Blanchot au début et que
maintenant vous allez un petit peu
durcir le ton donc je pense que c'est
vraiment un travail sur le discours un
travail sur l'acceptabilité et au fond
voilà pour le moment ça a été gagnant on
va voir si cette deuxième étape est
aussi populaire que les autres
le blocage du pays parce que c'est un
peu ce qui se profile à partir du 7 mars
même si on verra qu'il y a peut-être des
divergences stratégiques d'un syndicat
l'autre mais en tout cas c'est ce qui
est annoncé c'est peut-être un passage
obligé pour faire plier un gouvernement
mais est-ce que c'est là que l'opinion
bascule si on regarde un peu dans le
rétroviseur alors ça peut être un
effectivement un point de bascule en
réalité on voit bien que la situation
actuelle d'une certaine manière est
bloquée l'opinion publique qu'elle
s'exprime par les sondages on a toujours
deux tiers
quel que soit depuis un mois on a
toujours deux tiers de la population qui
est contre cette
évolutions mais il y a pas de
fléchissement ou de ou d'augmentation
majeure l'opinion publique quand elle
s'exprime par la manifestation
suscite une forte mobilisation aussi et
partout en France ça a été mis dans le
sujet et on l'a souvent détaillé dans ce
qu'on fasse le gouvernement fait des
concessions qui sont vus par l'opinion
publique mais qui sont jugés
insuffisantes parce que le cœur de la
réforme
mesure principale
l'âge de départ à 64 ans et les 43
années de cotisation ce sont des
éléments non négociables je reprends les
termes de l'exécutif qui sont
précisément ceux que l'opinion publique
juge le plus injuste et qu'il voudrait
et qu'elle voudrait voir retirer donc il
y a une situation de bras de fer de
blocage et pour en sortir il peut y
avoir la tentation pour les syndicats
d'accroître la pression pour faire céder
le gouvernement c'est une stratégie qui
risquée parce que en faisant cela c'est
à dire en créant des situations de
blocage une grève reconductible par
exemple avec toutes les conséquences que
ça peut avoir sur la mobilité des
Français sur évidemment la dimension
économique et dans le contexte actuel de
tension inflationnelle inflationniste ce
n'est pas neutre toutes ces conséquences
là pourraient faire reculer
le soutien de l'opinion publique au
mouvement donc les syndicats sont sur
une sorte de ligne de crête il faut
trouver un équilibre entre d'un côté
accroître cette pression politique sur
le gouvernement sans aliéner l'opinion
publique est-ce qu'ils ont vraiment le
choix Maxime qui joue est-ce que pour
faire plier un gouvernement on peut
parce que là on a le sentiment que les
journées de d'action de manifestation se
succèdent il y a souvent on peut dire
qu'il y a une démonstration de puissance
assez continue depuis quasiment un mois
bon et puis effectivement les
concessions s'il y en a vous l'avez dit
elles sont on a plus le sentiment
qu'elles sont faites aux parties l'air
que qu'aux syndicats dans les dans les
négociations donc est-ce qu'il y a une
autre option que celle du blocage du
pays donc dans une stratégie syndicale
alors dans un premier temps j'aimerais
juste réagir
jusqu'à présent il y a une grande
victoire symbolique des syndicats pour
trois points en fait le premier point
c'est la victoire du nombre puisqu'on a
vu que les manifestations se
maintenaient à des niveaux très élevés
au niveau des j'ai quand même comme vous
venez de le rappeler insouciant de la
population qui est extrêmement important
je crois que ça a pas vraiment baissé du
côté du monde salarié qui est
foncièrement opposé en fait à cette
réforme donc ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point c'est la victoire de
la crédibilité c'est à dire qu'il y a
une espèce de stratégie de l'escalier de
la part des syndicats qui consiste à
aller marche après marche et d'éviter un
mouvement fort et de grand ampleur tout
de suite c'est vrai la stratégie de
blocage c'était pas des dès la première
semaine ou même la
c'est on voit justement qui est encore
une espèce de temporalité les syndicats
jouent une temporalité tout à fait
intéressante donc une image de
crédibilité c'est-à-dire qu'on ne bloque
pas justement le pays dans un premier
temps et troisième point à une victoire
symbolique de proximité il faut quand
même le rappeler après l'épisode des
gilets jaunes où on avait dit que les
syndicats étaient éloignés des
territoires éloignés des gens etc là on
voit qu'il y a une forte mobilisation
qui n'est pas simplement un appel à la
mobilisation au niveau national mais qui
a un ancrage territorial de la part du
syndicalisme et symétriquement et je
finirai là-dessus c'est que forcément le
pouvoir apparaît isolé puisqu'il y a le
nombre le fait de nombre apparaît
jusqu'au-boutiste la raison la prudence
du syndicalisme et d'organisation
syndicale fait que en face le
gouvernement
s'il y a des blocages et des blocages
qui durent alors la responsabilité du
blocage
j'ai l'impression que je me tourne vers
le spécisme des sondages mais une grande
partie des Français sont pas opposées à
cette à cette option là alors après il
faudra se mettre dans le contexte ce
qu'effectivement quand on a commencé à
avoir des pénuries on peut avoir un
retournement de l'opinion mais jusqu'à
présent je pense que cette stratégie de
l'escalier du syndicalisme les
organisations syndicales est assez
efficace et même si ils perdent à la fin
la loi passe je pense que ça sera moins
une défaite du syndicalisme défaite
démocratique Mathieu
moi je suis frappé par l'extrême
sérénité de cet incertain parce qu'on
pourrait rajouter comme élément l'unité
quand même on a un mouvement uni depuis
le début il y a des différences de
stratégies il y a des différences
d'approches et on voit bien que tous ces
gens là arrivent à se parler les mots
ont un sens et vous remarquerez que le
mot qui employé par les syndicats c'est
France à l'arrêt c'est pas blocage c'est
une trouvaille de leur verger pour
éviter justement de de braquer une
partie de l'opinion et c'est vrai que il
y a pas de surprise dans la stratégie
syndicale c'est ça qui est frappant
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont alerté le
gouvernement à l'automne dernier en
disant attention ça passera pas alors
Auberger la répéter répéter Isabelle
Borg ils ont dit on va mobiliser là il
prévienne en amont donc on n'est pas
dans un mouvement un peu foutraque
radicalisé avec des débordements on n'a
pas vu d'ailleurs dans les manifs on est
dans un mouvement qui est plutôt serein
tenu avec c'est vrai démarche qui sont
franchies alors est-ce que ça est-ce que
ça créerait un rapport suffisant un
rapport de force suffisant pour faire
plier le pouvoir ça n'est pas sûr on se
souvient que en 95 qui est souvent
l'exemple qu'on donne tout ça dure trois
semaines puisque ça commence de mémoire
le 24 novembre et ça se résout la
mi-décembre le retrait du du plan JP là
on est sur du temps beaucoup plus long
mais face à un mouvement aussi serein et
j'allais dire une force tranquille d'une
certaine façon avec un leader qui se
dégage qui est Laurent Berger faut le
dire aussi je veux dire c'est c'est lui
qui porte cette intercendicale parce que
tout le monde fait son boulot mais
Philippe Martinez est plutôt sur le
départ et c'est la voix du syndicalisme
réformiste souvent accusé d'ailleurs de
trahison par ses pairs qui aujourd'hui
oppose un discours très très fort et
très ferme face à cette exécutif est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ça la patte
Laurent Berger en quelque sorte
peut-être Frédéric Michaud là-dessus
alors pour l'instant c'est vrai moi je
note comme vous la grande unité du front
syndical qui lors des réformes
précédentes c'est quand il y a une
cassure dans le front syndical que que
les réformes avancent c'est quand le
gouvernement arrive à
s'allier avec une centrale syndicale en
particulier
donc ça c'est évidemment un élément qui
doit être prise en compte par le par le
gouvernement il y a aussi un conflit
entre deux légitimités mais à la
légitimité des parlementaires il y a le
temps politique et puis il y a la
légitimité de l'opinion publique dans
les sondages et dans et dans la
manifestation et là il peut y avoir des
des éléments de calendrier qui peuvent
s'entrechoquer on voit bien que les
syndicats avec habileté enjambe les
vacances scolaires pour ne pas
reproduire ce qui s'était passé au
moment des vacances de Noël qui avait
été quand même assez désastreux en terme
avec le terme d'image
et mais est-ce que le le temps politique
ne va pas prendre de cours le temps de
la manifestation et des syndicats mais
je repose ma question un peu
différemment je reste avec vous est-ce
que parce que vous dites victoire
syndicale mais est-ce que pour autant le
lien de confiance entre les Français et
les syndicats qui étaient pas tellement
fort depuis quelques années se renforce
et ce que vous sentez ça est-ce que vous
sentez peut-être qu'il y a certains
leaders et peut-être Laurent Berger plus
que d'autres je ne sais pas qui en
tirent profit dans l'opinion alors pour
l'instant ce qu'on voit dans
effectivement l'image des syndicats
d'une manière générale se réhausse que
très clairement la responsabilité du
conflit actuel est attribuée au
président de la République à hauteur de
60% et seulement à hauteur de 20% au
syndicat donc là la répartition des
responsabilités et très claire et que
pour l'instant c'est plutôt le pouvoir
politique
l'exécutif le premier la première
ministre le président de la République
qui est qui sont mises en cause même si
ils sont pas dans une attitude
totalement intransigeante on voit qu'il
cherche aussi à ouvrir les positions à
faire des concessions en restant ferme
sur le fond de leur de leur réforme donc
on n'est pas j'allais dire dans dans une
situation d'opposition extrêmement figée
on sent quand même des d'une volonté de
rechercher des compromis qui est
d'ailleurs attendu de la part de
l'opinion publique mais jusqu'à présent
c'est vrai que les syndicats en et dans
l'opinion joue très bien et puis Anne
Charlène vésina le on l'a dit dans le
sujet de Jonathan duprise la première
ministre a téléphoné aux principaux
leaders syndicaux ce week-end sauf que
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est
d'abord avec elle a l'air qu'on a le
sentiment que la négociation se fait
depuis depuis des semaines on est dans
une espèce de
contre sens ou de contre-emploi d'une
certaine façon alors c'est très
compliqué aussi cette situation pour la
majorité parce qu'en fait on a un texte
sur le cas de la majorité s'engage mais
parce que c'était le texte
présidentielle il faut le savoir on est
même pas à deux jours de la première
manifestation qu'Emmanuel Macron nous
dit attention j'ai été élu là-dessus
donc j'irai jusqu'au bout donc ça c'est
vraiment on voit bien le message de
l'exécutif donc il y a cette idée de
tenir bon puis en même temps seul
puisque on le sait bien à part la
majorité personne ne soutient vraiment
ce texte donc il faut absolument des
alliances et évidemment c'est plus
opportun de parler à LR pour arriver à
faire aboutir ce texte au Parlement que
d'arriver à parler à un front syndical
dont on l'a dit non seulement il est uni
il est représentatif du peuple français
mais quels sont les marges de dialogue
avec eux le départ on le sait à partir
du moment où ça comporte un allongement
de la durée de départ et des durées de
cotisation la discussion n'est pas
possible donc de toute façon on
s'engageait forcément
et pas autrement et de l'autre on dit
bah si vous touchez pas au 64 ans on
peut pas discuter l'espèce d'habillage
de négociation qui s'est fait pendant
tout le mois de décembre en nous disant
décale parce qu'on veut plus de temps
pour la discussion qui finalement tombe
à l'eau puisqu'on on se rend bien compte
que la discussion non seulement n'a pas
eu lieu mais de toute façon des factônes
étaient plus ou moins pas possible donc
là c'est vraiment la rencontre de deux
blocs alors côté gouvernement ont mis
sur d'éventuelles divergences au sein de
l'intersyndicale c'est ce que disait le
ministre des Transports ce matin sur
Europe 1 écouter une note aussi qui a
des différences ou les divergences entre
organisations syndicales j'écoutais
Laurent bergère qui disait moi je parle
de la journée du 7 mars et il assumait
le
le mot les termes d'une France à l'arrêt
mais ils disaient c'est le 7 mars c'est
pas reconductible et pour plusieurs
jours et il y a d'autres organisations
syndicales je crois la CGT qui envisage
d'ores et déjà d'avoir plusieurs jours
de suite ce qui est vraiment très
différent je note qu'il y a des
différences on le sait l'histoire de
culture de positionnement entre une CFDT
qui a une culture de dialogue discussion
une CGT qui est plus radicale Maxime qui
joue dans les propos de Clément beau non
on le voit peut-être espérer que cette
inter syndicale solide se fissure à
partir du 8 mars est-ce que vous y
croyez à ça alors une fois de plus c'est
toujours difficile un peu de donner une
projection sur ce qui va se passer parce
que là on est ce qu'on appelle en
sciences politiques dans une conjonction
fluide c'est à dire qu'on va pas on peut
pas savoir trop ce qui va se passer mais
on peut essayer de d'émettre quelques
hypothèses ça dépend déjà premièrement
de la mobilisation du 7 mars est-ce que
s'il y a vraiment un taux de de grève et
de grévistes très important un arrêt
plus ou moins prononcé du pays et ben ça
va avoir du poids en fait dans la
continuité d'un mouvement et de la
stratégie syndicale la réaction du
gouvernement va aussi beaucoup sur avoir
d'importance mais sur ces pardon nous
interrompre c'est sur le mot
reconductible en fait c'est ce qu'on a
bien compris il y a peut-être y avoir
des des divisions de divergences on va
dire entre j'ai l'impression jusqu'à
présent que les uns et les autres en
fait réussissent à avoir une espèce de
partition multiple en fait au niveau
syndical chacun un peu dans une espèce
de convergence des luttes et que on
respecte en fait les modalités de lutte
des uns et des autres et j'ai
l'impression que ça va continuer alors
moi ce que je
l'une des hypothèses que je peux émettre
c'est que il va avoir une accentuation
on va dire de la mobilisation avec des
journées de moins en moins espacées et
avec peut-être Laurent Berger ne
surprend beaucoup peut-être un appel à
une reconduction au bout d'un moment
quand on voit qu'on est complètement
dans la page une espèce de va-tout
absolue qui serait pas complètement
surprenant on est vraiment dans ce que
je disais tout à l'heure une stratégie
de l'escalier marche après marche mais
qui pourrait voilà le s’accélérer en
fait à un moment juste le dernier point
là-dessus c'est que il faut pas oublier
et c'est ça que je pense qu'une grande
sagesse syndicale aussi dans cette
mobilisation c'est que on veut pas jeter
toutes nos forces dans la bataille et on
essaye de ménager les les forces
syndicales les forces aussi des
travailleurs parce qu'on sait que ça a
un coup la grève et donc il y a toute
cette idée là de essayer de maximiser la
lutte en fonction de du temps de la
lutte finalement Matthieu on va on va
s'intéressant à commencer à parler de la
stratégie du gouvernement mais si on
élargit à l'exécutif ce qui ce qui vous
frappe c'est quand même la discrétion du
prénom de la République oui parce que
lui qu'on a connu si volubile si
omniprésent sur tous les sujets capables
de tenir 5 heures sans fiches dans un
grand débat ou de dégainer vidéo sur
vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux pour nous
parler d'écologie de baccalauréat ou
même de son chien Nemo ben là il est où
le tiktoker en chef il a disparu
quelques confidences auprès de
journalistes quelques conseils dispensés
au Conseil des ministres une
justification à la sauce catalane depuis
Barcelone le jour de la première
manifestation à propos de cette réforme
vous y faisiez allusion Anne Charlène
juste responsable et démocratiquement
validé il y avait swing et Président on
a une petite mise en garde depuis
Bruxelles pour que les syndicats ne
bloquent pas l'agit du pays mais rien
d'autre pourquoi cette discrétion est-ce
que c'est de la prudence alors Jean-Luc
Mélenchon l'adversaire en chef il voit
un repli tactique s'il avait le bon goût
de parler dit Le Liseur dans un soumis
ce serait bien parce que ça améliorerait
le niveau de mobilisation populaire je
pense que c'est pour ça qu'il se tait
parce que c'est prudent de sa part alors
c'est sans doute vrai et une volonté de
pas rajouter de l'huile sur le feu il y
a une volonté de laisser la première
ministre jouer le rôle de paratonnerre
que lui confère nos institutions
peut-être une volonté de ne pas se salir
les mains je dirais les mauvaises
langues le chef de l'État va donc à ses
occupations et sont essentiellement
internationales car toutes sorties sur
le terrain hexagonale risquerait de se
transformer en prise à partie voir en
voilà en débat
avec avec le président mais qu'on se
rassure rassurez-vous tous un article du
Parisien ce matin nous explique que tout
cela est pensé que le chef de l'État
suit tout ça très près en sous-main les
débats la conduite des débats la réforme
la conduite de la réforme jusqu'à
décider qui parmi les ministres sera
autorisé à s'exprimer dans les médias
c'est dire alors on peut quand même
considérer que effectivement ne pas
apparaître en première ligne c'est un
bon calcul mais ça se veut sans doute
malin très malin sans doute un peu trop
malin même vous souvenez de cette phrase
de Gilles Legendre l'ancien des député
macronistes on a fait trop intelligent
trop subtil car enfin s'il y a une
partie de poker menteur qui se joue
entre l'exécutif et l'opposition à
l'Assemblée les syndicats et les
français eux sont pas invités à la table
et au sommet de l'État personne ne les
écoute personne ne leur parle à part
deux trois coups de fil d'Elizabeth
borne et mais surtout personne ne les
prend en compte en est quand même à
quatre journées de mobilisation qui ont
mis à chaque fois plus d'un million de
personnes dans la rue partout en France
l'opinion publique on en parlait sondage
après sondage affiche son rejet de la
réforme mais aussi elles ne comprend pas
l'utilité et on a des syndicats qui
manifeste chaque fois dans le calme sans
que jamais sans trouve la moindre porte
de négociation voire même de discussion
et on se dit que d'une certaine façon
euh ce président que ce président muet
et ce gouvernement sourd ont quand même
bien de la chance que les syndicats
gardent leurs mains dans les poches et
la tête sur les épaules plutôt que de
laisser éclater leur exaspération ils
sont responsables pour deux voire pour
trois si on y ajoute l'opposition dans
une singulière inversion des rôles
unchard bizarres est-ce que c'est
surprenant il y a plusieurs thèmes dans
le papier de Mathieu on va on va pouvoir
s'appuyer dessus d'abord le silence
présidentielle est-ce que c'est
finalement
surprenant dans un contexte comme
celui-là dans des réformes comme
celle-là alors c'est surprenant par
rapport à l'homme comme vous l'appeliez
le tik token en chef et néanmoins pas
particulièrement par rapport à la
pratique de nos institutions je crois je
crois même que quand vous parliez
paratonnerre on est complètement là
dedans c'est-à-dire que la parole
présidentielle elle a à la fois se faste
qui fait qu'on l'attend et qu'on est
toujours au premier rang pour la
critiquer donc c'est très difficile de
savoir quand la dégainé et elle est
vraiment réservée aux périodes de crise
aux périodes où on a besoin de l'unité
nationale on lui a beaucoup reproché
d'ailleurs à la suite de la sortie des
urnes de mai de ne pas faut savoir pris
la parole plus souvent de ne pas avoir
donné le cap un petit peu outre cette
réforme des retraites justement donc je
pense que moi vrai avec le quinquennat
ou le le passage c'est à dire que ça
expose quand même un peu plus le
président de la République on a vu un
Premier ministre qui était parfois
qualifié de collaborateurs par Nicolas
Saxe enfin bref il y a le le l'équilibre
du duo c'est un peu transformé quand
même oui et notamment c'est assez
paradoxal de voir que le président ne
prend pas la parole et que pourtant
cette réforme lui est entièrement
attribué dans l'opinion justement je
parle sous contrôle de Monsieur mais
c'est ce que vous nous disiez c'est lui
qui prend cette responsabilité donc
comme vous le disiez au fond le
président est conçu comme responsable de
tout par les Français et c'est sûrement
la vérité puisque on le sait le cap
gouvernemental c'est le cap présidentiel
mais la posture d'aller au front de
prendre la parole un 20h dans par
exemple ces conditions serait à mon avis
vraiment de l'ordre de la communication
de crise donc on serait loin peut-être
dans ce conflit et je crois que c'est
vraiment pas le message pense que le
président a envie de donner
Emmanuel Macron de prendre la parole à
20h là
mais c'est vrai que le quinquennat
expose davantage le président par la
force des choses surtout quand on a un
premier ministre ou une première
ministre qui est plutôt technique que
politique et surtout quand on n'a pas de
ministre fort de poids lourds au
gouvernement qui sont en capacité de
porter une retraite en 2010 c'était déjà
le quinquennat
Eric wurt avait beaucoup plus de poids
politique que peuvent en avoir les
ministres qui aujourd'hui sont censés
porter cette réforme des des retraites
donc il y a aussi une différence qui est
liée à la personnalité des ministres qui
composent le gouvernement ce qu'on
observe aussi c'est que les codes de
popularité du président de la République
comme d'Elizabeth borne tendance à
fléchir depuis le début du conflit et à
retrouver des niveaux historiquement
très bas et ça si ce mouvement devait
prolonger évidemment ça enlèverait un
petit peu plus de légitimité politique à
l'action de l'un comme de l'autre mais
lui aussi peut garder Mathieu peut
garder stratégiquement c'est ses
cartouches bien sûr
une prise de parole à un moment après on
peut imaginer une prise de parole
extrêmement solennelle comme la viande
Charlène à 20h alors là c'est vraiment
une adresse à tous les Français ça nous
rappelle le covid les vœux du 31
décembre enfin on est sur des formats
très très solennelles j'allais dire mais
il y a mille façons de faire aussi il y
a peut-être un moment où quelqu'un au
sommet de l'État va se dire est-ce qu'on
reçoit les leaders syndicaux par exemple
et quand vous avez je le disais 4
manifestations de suite qui se passent
dans le calme dans l'ordre avec ce côté
force tranquille et que vous dites non
non c'est bon ils ont le droit de
manifester mais on ira jusqu'au bout il
y a un moment quelqu'un va devoir
dénouer cette crise donc ça c'est un
format possible après il en a inventé
milf des formats Emmanuel Macron je
parlais des réseaux sociaux mais je vais
que ce soit dans la presse que ce soit
quand il faut parler il y a mille façons
de parler il faut juste trouver la bonne
mais je pense que c'est vrai de timing
c'est le ce qui est important c'est le
moment et que pour l'instant il ne juge
pas que le moment cette critique elle
est évidemment évidemment aussi exprimée
par Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'était ce samedi
lors de des manifestations quoi qu'on
fasse c'est comme si on ne faisait rien
quoi qu'on dise c'est comme si on ne
disait rien alors qu'est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est du mépris est-ce que
c'est une volonté d'essayer de faire
craquer les gens à force d'usure en
quelque sorte donc c'est très mal
ressenti parce que les syndicats leur
tradition c'est la négociation à tous
autant qu'ils sont donc ils ont
l'habitude que bon quand jetons commence
à monter un peu bon on discutait là on
discute pas le pouvoir
macroniste et là ancré dans ses
positions essaie de faire peur
d'intimider de dire aux gens ou perdrez
de l'argent en vain bon en faisant grève
etc c'est très mal vécu Maxime qui joue
le président de la République a commencé
son premier quinquennat on peut le dire
en snobant plutôt les corps
intermédiaires parce que finalement
n'est pas il a dit échanger je vais vous
proposer une gouvernance différente mais
est-ce qu'on n'est pas un peu dans cette
continuité là moi je force et de
constater qu'on a à faire une espèce de
caporalisation du direct démocratique en
fait c'est à dire que on assiste à
effectivement
l'idée que seul en fait la personne du
président de la République a autorité
sur l'ensemble des décisions du pays
sauf que la tradition démocratique même
si on est élu pousse aussi d'autres
formes démocratiques et les syndicats
sont des forces démocratiques il faut
pas l'oublier ils ont une onction
électorale également donc il y a une
espèce même si les Français sont quand
même peu syndiqués mais c'est pas une
question
que les Français salariés votent votent
les élections professionnelles sont des
élections qui sont relativement suivies
entre entre autour de 70% de
participation donc ce sont des espaces
démocratiques importants et
effectivement même si les organisations
syndicales
peut s'indiquer pour des raisons
spécifiques à la France ou le
syndicalisme est une espèce de
participation militante plus qu'une
syndicalisation un peu forcée qu'on
pourrait retrouver dans d'autres pays
européens elle est quand même marquée
d'une légitimité démocratique que le
Président de la République visiblement a
oublié je pense j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a un problème de culture politique
finalement c'est à dire qu'on a affaire
à quelqu'un qui vient d'un espace qui
n'était pas l'espace politique et j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a une espèce de
rupture en fait en ce moment et qui est
très forte et qui se marque en fait par
l'absence absolue de négociation avec
les corps intermédiaires caporalisations
est-ce que vous reprenez ce terme que
que ce qui vous fait réagir il y a
quelque chose en tout cas de réel
là-dedans c'est que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
parlait de culture du dialogue dans dans
la syndicalisation dans l'histoire
sociale française finalement c'est à
dire que c'est vrai que l'idée c'est que
chacun montre un petit peu les muscles
et puis que à force on en arrive à
dialoguer ici finalement on le voit bien
de depuis le départ le gouvernement a
choisi un cap sur lequel il
plus que du caporalisme moi je trouve
que c'est Emmanuel Macron pourra
peut-être faire passer sa réforme mais
il aura échoué à quelque chose c'est à
sortir ce pays de l'immaturité politique
et démocratique il fait comme les autres
à la façon des autres des lois qui sont
contestées dans la rue et qu'il
appliquent fermement il y avait une
promesse dans sa première élection en
tout cas de renouveau de faire autrement
d'inventer une autre forme de démocratie
que ce soit au Parlement avec la
proportionnelle ou que ce soit dans une
culture du dialogue de la négociation de
la conciliation voire de la coalition un
peu comme certains de nos partenaires
européens sur ce point de vue c'est un
échec total vous dites même qu'on est
peut-être à l'aube d'une crise de régime
pourquoi vous en posiez cette expression
parce qu'en fait j'ai le sentiment que
il ne peut pas y avoir de bons résultats
à l'issue de cette crise que nous vivons
si le gouvernement abandonne sa réforme
c'est un échec de la démocratie élective
et une victoire de la population
syndiquée mais si le gouvernement va au
bout de cette réforme avec les
mécanismes parlementaires que lui la
Constitution c'est un échec pour
l'assise populaire de ce gouvernement
donc de toute façon on est dans un
schéma si on reprend Nicolas Sarkozy
avec le gagnant-gagnant là on est dans
le perdant perdant de toute façon
puisque personne n'a intérêt à ce que il
y a un échec des deux et peut-être qu'on
se rencontre que finalement si les
mécanismes constitutionnels permettent
au Parlement de faire passer des lois
qui ont la certitude de cliver à ce
point-là le peuple français c'est quand
même qu'il y a un problème de de forte
étanchéité entre les deux
les deux circuits qui sont quand même
censés communiquer et c'est le principe
de cette nouvelle méthode c'est même le
principe sur lequel est assis la
démocratie donc là on aurait une
tentation de d'opposer les représentants
aux représentés faut faire attention
c'est ça qui a quand même démarré la
crise des gilets jaunes
au début de ce mouvement il y avait
ce soutien populaire qui est ou de tiers
des Français mais en même temps l'idée
que de toute façon la réforme elle
allait passer une espèce de de fatalisme
est-ce que ce fatalisme est toujours là
alors il se maintient il se maintient et
à un niveau élevé aux alentours de 70%
70% des Français qui s'attendent à ce
que la réforme soit votée et soit
appliquée et ça évidemment c'est un
indicateur qui pour l'instant joue très
largement en faveur du du gouvernement
sentiment de fatalisme l'idée que de
toute façon les jeux sont joués et c'est
sans doute un point sur lequel s'appuie
le gouvernement si cet indicateur venait
à se dégrader on serait dans une
configuration politique bien différente
avec un élément de risque d'opinion
beaucoup plus élevé pour pour le
gouvernement c'est intéressant aussi de
noter que
rétrospectivement si on regarde la
réforme de 2019 là aussi on avait eu une
situation de de blocage qui s'était
étalé sur plusieurs jours et même sur
plusieurs semaines sans que le
gouvernement ne cède sur une réforme qui
était de d'une ampleur beaucoup plus
importante c'était une réforme du
système des retraites
la grande différence a été en étant le
soutien de la CFDT dès le début oui mais
je veux dire aussi que face à blocage
important le gouvernement avait tenu et
donc peut-être qu'il est aussi dans
cette d'une certaine manière en tout cas
le chef de l'État dans cet état d'esprit
qui est renforcé évidemment par le fait
qu'il a fait du vote de cette réforme un
élément majeur de son quinquennat et que
comme vous l'avez bien dit si la
bandonne cette réforme s'il s'aide sur
cette réforme le reste de son mandat
sera sérieusement handicapé et sa
légitimité politique fortement
détériorée on va parler maintenant du
gras Saint-Quentin calmé qui est juste
derrière le rideau de sciences publiques
bonsoir Quentin bienvenue de d'un
élément crucial évidemment l'un peut
évoqué mais très rapidement dans ce
débat éléments crucial dans cette
réforme des retraites c'est le
calendrier
parlementaire l'examen de cette loi au
Parlement oui c'est vrai que depuis fin
janvier on voit un double mouvement
celui des mobilisations syndicales dans
la rue et également celui de la séance
au Parlement et de plus en plus les
syndicats qui s'organisent pour que leur
date de manifestation collent avec des
moments forts de cette séance dans
l'hémicycle l'exemple avec la prochaine
date de mobilisation l'intersyndicale
qui appelle à battre le pavé le 16
février ce sera alors la cinquième
journée d'action et bien c'est un moyen
de mettre de la pression sur les députés
car c'est la veille du dernier jour de
l'examen de la réforme en séance à
l'Assemblée nationale l'idée est donc
bien de peser sur le débat parlementaire
qui doit se terminer pour les députés
vendredi soir à minuit a priori et le
texte est ensuite transmis au scénariste
justement la deuxième date qui est déjà
fixée par la terre syndicale là aussi
elle peut être liée au calendrier du
Sénat voilà c'est ce qui est
effectivement écrit les syndicalistes
dans leur communiquer si malgré tout le
gouvernement et les parlementaires
restaient sourds à la contestation
populaire l'as inter syndicale
appellerait à durcir le mouvement en
mettant la France à l'arrêt c'est là
qu'ils ont utilisé cette expression dans
tous les secteurs le 7 mars c'est qu'ils
ont écrit samedi dernier alors pourquoi
cette date déjà parce que nous serons en
plein dans l'examen du texte au Sénat
regardez plutôt le texte arrive en
séance le 2 mars aussi à la Chambre
haute pour être examinée tous les jours
week-end compris jusqu'au 12 mars la
date maximum pour les sénateurs autre
raison de cette date du 7 mars ce sera
la fin des vacances scolaires depuis
plusieurs jours on entendait les
syndicats dire que ce serait un moment
important pour relancer le mouvement
écouter par exemple Benoît test à la FSU
un syndicat qui compte beaucoup
d'enseignants et qui nous a explicité
cette stratégie
bon maintenir la mobilisation à haut
niveau donc probablement il faudra de
nouveau temps forts et prévoir d'ores et
déjà que le fait de monter d'un cran ça
sera la semaine du 6 mars pour nous il
faudra que dès que toutes les zones
seront rentrées le 6 mars on organise un
truc qui est monté encore en puissance
la barre est très haute donc on dit ça
avec toute l'humilité qui est la nôtre
et il faut que les salariés nous suivent
il faut qu'il y ait plus de monde encore
qui viennent dans les mobilisations mais
on y compte bien et on y croit et on
pense que c'est possible on va Thomas
tout va donc s'accélérer à partir de la
semaine du 6 mars en l'occurrence à
partir du 7 mars puisque dans le même
temps vont être lancés les premiers
grèves reconductibles c'est le cas dans
les transports assez se qu'annoncés la
CGT cheminot laisse syndicats vont donc
faire monter la pression d'un cran bien
supérieur et ce sera pile au moment de
la fin de l'examen du texte au Sénat
merci beaucoup Quentin Maxime qui joue
est-ce qu'il y a une stratégie alors
c'est une question qui est un peu
vieille comme les les mouvements
syndicaux elle est très longtemps on
parlait de la CGT et un petit communiste
français d'une stratégie comme les
est-ce qu'il y a est-ce que voilà est-ce
que d'après vous il y a des échanges une
stratégie commune entre la Nupe au
Parlement en ce moment à l'Assemblée et
voilà les dates le les choix faits par
le mouvement syndical je crois pas je
crois que je pose la question ouverte il
y a dans le premier sujet on a entendu
Philippe Martinez ce qu'il disait
j'aimerais bien quand même que que
l'article 7 qui est l'article qui porte
la musique soit examiner et discuter à
l'Assemblée
différentes voire divergentes en fait
sur la façon de bloquer le texte j'ai
l'impression que la nuque est dans une
perspective d'obstruction pour éviter le
débat avec une idée peut-être que
derrière le Conseil constitutionnel dans
un contexte de forte mobilisation
rejette finalement le texte pour des
raisons alors je suis pas juriste mais
pour des régions juridiques et mais
aussi pour des raisons sociales et alors
que la stratégie syndicale est plutôt
basée sur l'idée de laisser le travail
les démocratique parlementaires
s'exprimer et ensuite de faire ce qu'on
dirait d'un heiming and sheming des
désigner en fait les responsables
politiques de leur action démocratique
néfastes en fait pour la réforme et pour
les et pour les salariés alors justement
on en parlait de cette stratégie de la
nuque je vous propose d'entendre Gabriel
Attal ministre de l'action des comptes
publics sur les 20000 et quelques
moments déposés par la nuque
vous avez de la part des oppositions un
choix qui est celui de bloquer le débat
avec 20000 amendements qui ont été
déposés il faut regarder les amendements
quand vous avez un amendement qui dit on
va remplacer le mot index senior dans la
loi par index feuille de salade car
c'est ça qui est écrit quand on va faire
une batterie d'amendement pour dire la
réforme des retraites va rentrer en
vigueur en 2050 en 2060 en 2060
d'un tel spectacle et d'une telle
situation je voudrais nous reste elle
est un peu plus de 5 minutes qu'on parle
quand même de des violences verbales à
l'Assemblée nationale de dernier en date
c'était en cette fin d'après-midi un
député lfhorien c'est un tout le qui a
traité Olivier du soft d'un poster et
d'assassin en pleine séance la séance a
été suspendue Unchained usina est-ce que
est-ce que c'est particulièrement
violent là aussi si on fait un peu
d'histoire
républicaine l'assemblée a été dans
notre histoire le lieu de violence
verbale de violence physique parfois
est-ce que c'est une période
particulière
Oui au niveau de la tension au niveau
aussi du climat qu'on retrouve être un
petit peu le même dans la rue etc enfin
on voit qu'il on voit qu'il y a un
dialogue de sourd on en a déjà plusieurs
fois parlé néanmoins en termes de
tradition parlementaire je suis pas sûr
qu'on puisse vraiment parler de alors
peut-être pas ton passé un cran mais
notre tradition parlementaire est
vraiment celle de la violence c'est le
marché d'Astérix on a des microfiltrés
comme on les aurait pour des festivals à
l'extérieur tellement on n'entend pas
les gens parler puisque tout le monde se
crie dessus ça c'est vraiment la manière
dont on a de débattre depuis 1791 ça a
toujours été le cas sur la Troisième
République on racontait même que tout se
terminer par des duels entre les
Français
des périodes de corps-à-corps néanmoins
c'est vrai que quand on entend voilà
dans le compte rendu des débats quand on
voit je vais en venir aux mains quand on
voit des invectifs personnels j'irai il
y a peut-être un niveau de
personnalisation dans les atteintes qui
sont faites aux députés qui est un petit
peu inédite et j'ai le sentiment aussi
qu'on a en plus le sentiment qu'il n'y a
que ça dans ce débat parce que il y a
même plus de discussion sur le il y a
juste des gens qui se crient les uns sur
les autres alors que avant ça faisait
partie d'un théâtre plus général donc on
a tendance à plus porter l'oeil par
rapport au fait aussi qu'on a on a plus
que ça à se mettre sous la douche
autre député les filles qui a posé cette
photo avec un ballon avec les figures de
vie du stop il a été d'ailleurs soutenu
à Thomas porte par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est un peu c'est un
peu la stratégie Frédéric Michaud
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a cette créer du
conflit pour réveiller les consciences
populaires c'est la stratégie de du
leader de les filles depuis longtemps
c'est porté
par une forme de disons de de présence
assez assez forte à l'Assemblée
nationale
les exaspérations les frustrations qui
peuvent exister dans l'ensemble de la
société donc ça c'est une fonction de
représentation on porte la colère du
peuple et effectivement cette partie de
l'hémicycle s'inscrit dans cette
tradition qui est effectivement une
tradition française de de conflits
idéologique qui verbalement peut-être la
différence par rapport à ce qui était
observé précédemment c'est la caisse de
résonance des réseaux sociaux qui
donnent de la visibilité à des éléments
qui auparavant étaient simplement
retranscrits dans les débats et quand on
voit les choses couchées sur le papier
ça n'a évidemment pas le même effet que
quand on les voit en vidéo mais mais
cette tradition politique surtout dans
des périodes sur des textes très
conflictuels elle a toujours existé
seulement aujourd'hui on la voit
davantage l'excès et l'injure avis la
politique c'est ce que disait à la une
de nos confrères du Parisien Aujourd'hui
en France hier ce dimanche l'ancien
Premier ministre et l'ancien ministre de
l'Intérieur Bernard Cazeneuve mais que
pèse encore cette gauche
de Bernard Cazeneuve
j'ai envie de dire toute partie
socialiste au tissu a quand même fait
1,75% à la présidentielle juste pour
rebondir je dirais que c'est pas
forcément plus violent mais il y a moins
de talent et on est davantage dans un
niveau d'agressivité moi c'est ça qui me
frappe
uncharlen la souligné d'agressivité
personnelle et pas forcément dans une
stratégie de grands orateurs qui
échangent des arguments il y a plus ça
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que les
réseaux sociaux ont changé la donne
avant les députés les sénateurs venaient
très présents la musique au moment des
séances de questions au gouvernement qui
était retransmises à la télévision mais
c'est à peu près le seul moment
aujourd'hui chacun peut avoir son petit
morceau bravo et d'ailleurs ils font
leur auto promo eux-mêmes en retwitant
en reposant leur tirade donc ça fait pas
progresser le débat ça c'est sûr parce
que pour l'instant on a on a très peu
parlé du fond un petit peu dans
l'articulant ce régime spéciaux mais
certainement pas sur ce sur la suite et
c'est calamiteux pour l'image que ça
renvoie du Parlement quand on dit que
les gens sont coupés de la politique le
spectacle qui est donné toutes
oppositions toute majorité confondues et
quand même assez désolant oui et il y en
a une qui est elle aussi très discrète
avec Micha c'est Marine Le Pen
alors oui est-ce que cette discrétion
lui profite
là aussi on est dans une logique par
rapport à sa volonté de respectabilité
de recherche de responsabilité de
contraste et les saisissante quand les
députés et les filles sont dans la
violence verbale les députés RN sauf
rares exception sociale mais c'est une
logique de communication
depuis le début de la législature de
vouloir à la fois jouer le contraste
avec disons l'autre partie de
l'hémicycle l'autre extrême dans
l'hémicycle et puis cette recherche de
oui de respectabilité cette volonté
d'apparaître en capacité d'exercer des
des fonctions gouvernementales lors des
prochaines lors des prochaines échéances
ça passe par ce comportement plus stable
plus plus calme alors c'est pas toujours
bien maîtrisé mais en tout cas ce sont
les consignes qui sont données par par
Marine Le Pen à son groupe
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce débat bientôt sur
sur public